[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
من الطرق المستخدمه عند العرب قديما
وحديثا في معرفه دخول وخروج الفصول
والمواسم
الظل وهي من ادق الطرق الحسابيه عندهم وهل
الاولين الله يرحمهم يقولون اطول حالات
الظل الزوالي في السنه دليل على دخول
مربعانيه الشتاء واقصر حالات الظل الزوال
في السنه دليل على دخول مربعانيه القيض
واذا توسط طول الظل الزوالي اعتدى الزمان
ومن دقه الظل جعله المولى علامه على دخول
مواقيت الصلاه اقيم الصلاه لدلوك الشمس
الى غسق الليل وقران الفجر ان قران الفجر
كان مشهودا فصلاتيه الظهر والعصر على الظل
المباشر وصلاتي العشاء والفجر على الظل
الغير مباشر وصلاه المغرب مع مغيب الشمس
والظل
من ايات الله الم تر الى ربك كيف مد الظلم
ولو شاء لجعله ساكنا ثم جعلنا الشمس عليه
دليلا فاطول حالات الظل اليوميه في حال
شروق وغروب الشمس واقصر حالات الظل
اليوميه في حال الزوال مرات والديبي معك
مثل ظلي ومرات ودي انك اقرب من الظل تبي
الصراحه يا بعد كل اللي وانت معي ما همني
غيبت
الكل
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]